eu ratspräsidentschaft zum zweiten mal
übernimmt angela merkel das ruder
zusammen mit ursula von der leyen als
präsidentin der eu kommission
lassen wir uns also das motto unserer
ratspräsidentschaft mit leben erfüllen
gemeinsam europa wieder stark machen
herzlichen dank 750 milliarden corona
aufbau fonds rexit klimawandel
digitalisierung jugendarbeitslosigkeit
ist das zu schaffen
deutschland hat sich in der finanzkrise
2008 der flüchtlingskrise 2015 und der
korona krise bewährt kann merkel auch
europa was gut für europa ist war und
ist gut für uns für merkel die letzte
möglichkeit in ihrer kanzlerschaft ein
bedeutendes vermächtnis zu hinterlassen
ein power du in brüssel also kurz
zusammengefasst 27 chefs der eu
mitgliedstaaten treffen sich jetzt ohne
debattieren runde diskutieren darüber
was denn jetzt gut ist mit verschiedenen
themen wie corona oder die klimakrise
und das ganze wird organisiert und
moderiert quasi von den beiden ladys was
ich mir angedacht hat das ist ja
irgendwie ein cooles gefühl dass zu
sehen ich war stolz und auch cluster die
auch so ein bisschen beruhigt und du
patricia doors ja eben in brüssel ein
bisschen gearbeitet und kannst du ein
bisschen aus dem nähkästchen plaudern
da was machen die denn da den ganzen tag
naja also wie das gerade stand gesagt
hat für die wichtigen entscheidungen
braucht es eben die zustimmung von 27
eu-mitgliedsstaaten so also das was wir
gerade im beitrag gesehen haben kann
frau merkel gar nicht alles leisten in
schneiders darlegen da ihre große
aufgabe wird sein dass sie einen geist
der solidarität erschafft also dass sie
einen zusammenhalt erschafft und ich
hoffe dass ihr das gelingt und ich
glaube auch dass ihr das gelingt aber
man muss sagen als ich als journalistin
dort war die eu-ratspräsidentschaft
wechselt alle sechs monate und
journalisten haben das vor allem daran
bemerkt dass im foyer des ministerrats
eine neue deko inland und ist sie muss
sich nämlich immer an das land anpassen
und nehmen immer witze darüber gemacht
ja das ist die einzige schnelle
entscheidung lieber nämlich wenn man die
eu ratspräsidentschaft innehat treffen
kann die deko ob irgendeiner
springbrunnen steht oder ob dort hilfen
gartenzwerge stehen und deswegen finde
ich darf man dieses thema jetzt nicht
überbewerten und sagen sie muss jetzt
mal kurz in china
exit corona also der jahre ist der stirn
schauen wo es mehr darum geht dass sie
einen gemeinsamen geist der solidarität
ja aber nebenbei ist auch zufällig
kanzlerin noch so ein bisschen mehr sie
das sehen
eigentlich ist es so dass sie dann
denken große bewunderung was diese
beiden frauen machen oder haben sie ihr
eine sorge weil sie haben ja selbst vor
einiger zeit sich etwas zurückgezogen
weil sie übrigens extrem mutig fand und
zugesagt ganz klar mir wird es ein
bisschen zu viel leute ich konzentriere
mich mal und orientiere mich mal ein
bisschen um wenn sie die beiden
ehefrauen sehen was denken sie dann ja
also ich meine es sind ja immer
regierungschefs oder regierungschefinnen
die also diese funktion mit übernehmen
das ist schon sommer der die belastung
die man hat und die kanzlerin hat eine
extreme belastung muss man sagen frau
merkel geht damit ja jetzt seit vielen
vielen jahren sehr souverän um
also ich glaube physisch und so das
schafft sie alles was ich schon mir
wünschen würde aber ob das eingelöst
wird habe ich zweifel ich finde europa
muss souveräner werden also wenn wir uns
angucken wie sich trump verhält wie die
usa vielfach wirklich gegen unsere
interessen politik machen brauchen wir
in europa auch den zusammenhalt deshalb
um einfach unsere eigenen interessen
stärker vertreten zu können und wenn das
jetzt befördert wird wäre das super aber
dafür muss man eben auch in europa mehr
einigkeit haben und wir haben eben einen
eine sehr gespalten eu wir haben auch
eine spaltung in den einzelnen ländern
also die ungleichheit wächst und damit
sind viele leute auch unzufrieden mit
der europäischen union weil sie immer
nur auf markt setzt auf marktgläubigkeit
große unternehmen werden gefördert
und ich finde wir brauchen europa
projekte wo es einfach für die ganz
normalen leute spürbar wird das macht
mein leben besser das hilft mir das
stützt mich dass es meine verringert
meine soziale unsicherheit und solche
projekte gibt es bisher eigentlich so
gut an zu wenig aber kein frau merkel
das schaffen was meinen sie alleine
nicht also sie haben ja völlig recht
also das ist eben kein bundesstaat
sondern es ist ein staatenbund und ich
bin allerdings der meinung das ist auch
gut so
also ich hielt es nicht für gut wenn man
jetzt sagen würde also alle macht nach
brüssel eine zentrale und dirigiert
jetzt quasi über uns es gibt ja leute
die das vertreten ich glaube das geht
nicht das würde unsere demokratie
zerstören aber dass man zusammenarbeit
warum so schwer
entscheidungen zu treffen die wie sie
gerade beschrieben haben den kleinen
mann glücklich machen weil das eben ein
entscheidungen sind die die einzelnen
länder und das kann man eigentlich auch
nicht dann der eu überstülpen
ich denke schon das überstülpen kann und
ich glaube das ist auch die große
herausforderung bei dem thema
europäische union dass sie eben auch als
werte union nur verstanden werden kann
wenn sich auch den menschen vermittelt
was sie von der europäischen union ganz
persönlich in ihrem ganz konkreten
alltag haben und ich sage mal wenn
europa für etwas steht dann hoffe ich
doch für die sicherung von frieden und
freiheit und im zeitalter der
globalisierung nicht nur als sozusagen
mit der korona epidemie sind wir haben
viele andere probleme sage ich mal was
das thema beispielsweise klimaschutz
angeht immigrationspolitik asylpolitik
schauen wir uns an auch was denn an den
außengrenzen der eu los ist das ist das
gegenteil von freiheit und frieden
die frage ist nur was ist unsere antwort
darauf und damit glaube ich schon auch
also aus meiner sicht ist sozusagen auch
eine uneinige eu immer noch besser als
die fragmentierung von nationalstaaten
und das ist nun mal so und das ist das
besondere momente von eu dass wir auch
mit rechts konservativen regierungen
ländern wie polen und ungarn genau so
zurecht kommen müssen und dass da
sozusagen ja auch nicht die bessere
politik gemacht wird und dass deswegen
natürlich europa ist ihm und eben nicht
in diesem einzelkampf heraus natürlich
ganz andere erwägungen auch erzielen
muss aber ich glaube gerade jetzt in
zeiten der globalisierung insbesondere
was sozusagen die antwort angeht auf die
usa als weltpolizei die dafür nicht mehr
in frage kommt aber auch russland auf
der anderen seite also wir haben sehr
sehr viele herausforderungen und da
brauchen wir eine starke eu und ich
glaube eine starke eu und das ist
vielleicht der denkfehler heißt auch
eine eu die uneins ist aber ich denke
das narrativ dass sich das vermittelt
auch in die gesellschaft des
kleinbürgers hinein
da könnten und müssten wir viel mehr
machen kleines beispiel corona als
plötzlich die grenzen dicht gemacht
worden sind was hat das für gefühle bei
uns ausgelöst weil wir plötzlich
verstanden haben schenken freiraum ist
ja doch keine selbstverständlichkeit
also ich denke da haben wir eben eine
menge zu tun
gc ist es ja auch so dass frau merkel
sich etwas zurückziehen möchte meinen
sie dass sie vielleicht jetzt eine kurze
duftmarken hinterlassen möchte zum
schluss damit man
noch mehr sieht was man dann später
bleibt verpasst oder nicht mehr hat ja
also meistens bei uns frauen sondern das
war versteht man ja erst später als weg
sind auf jeden fall glaube ich ist das
jetzt für sie noch mal ein höhepunkt
ihrer kanzlerschaft und vielleicht hat
sie auch das bedürfnis dinge wieder gut
zu machen
also es ist ja nicht längst zum beispiel
ja also deutschland hat ja schon in der
vergangenheit auch dazu beigetragen dass
in anderen ländern dass sie gesagt haben
die haben auch nur ihre eigenen
interessen also zum beispiel wird in
vielen ländern kritisiert dass in
deutschland teilweise sehr sehr
schlechte arbeitsverhältnisse zugelassen
werden wir haben das jetzt in der
fleischindustrie diesen skandal also
dass und werkverträge das ist in keinem
anderen land so legal und das hatte die
folge dass wir in deutschland eben mit
diesem billigfleisch im grunde die ganze
fleischindustrie in europa zerstört
haben also woanders sind die
arbeitsplätze kaputtgegangen sowie
dänemark die zahlen 25 euro tariflohn in
der schlachterei also bei den arbeitern
so und hier zahlen sie halt diesen
wanderarbeitern die völlig rechtlos sind
über diese konstruktionen 1000 euro im
monat vielleicht nicht mal für für
endlos viel arbeitszeit und die anderen
europäer haben gesagt ja damit zerstört
ihr unsere arbeitsplätze warum schafft
ihr solche solche unmöglichen ausbeutung
es ist wirklich interessant sogar ungarn
und polen ungarische und polnische
unternehmen haben in deutschland
geschlachtet weil sie offenbar in ihren
eigenen ländern so katastrophale
situation nicht haben also das ist
wirklich frappierend und deswegen
natürlich ist das lohnniveau im osten
niedriger als bei uns aber deutschland
ist inzwischen der zweitgrößte fleisch
schweinefleisch exporteur der welt
geworden und in der eu leben wirklich
also absolut dominieren mit solchen
fleisch baronen wie turniers und andere
und ich finde unsere stärke muss doch
nicht sein mit solchen
ausbeutungsverhältnisse international
den wettbewerb aufzurollen sondern wir
müssen doch auf hochtechnologie setzen
wir müssen auf die seele das ist
natürlich aber dass auch ein ganz ganz
schwierig ist und auch ein sehr
wichtiges thema die berge regel die mir
jetzt sozusagen ja ich sag mal die
politik hat das immer gewusst wir haben
das immer wieder im bundestag
ich weiß ich habe nämlich vorhin
deswegen da möchte ich nämlich wirklich
darauf zu sprechen kommen das haben wir
auch nämlich ganz eifrig diskutiert dass
wir diesen entschluss zu sagen ich trete
kürzer was sich eingehend von ihm gesagt
habe was sie gemacht haben hat mir so
mutig was war das für sie auch bar oder
war ihnen das bewusst dass sie gesagt
haben okay ich mache das jetzt und ich
traue mich jetzt das zu sagen
also ich weiß gar nicht ob das mutig ist
ich habe einfach irgendwann gemerkt dass
ich mich völlig verschleiß und ich mein
ich bin hier die politik gegangen um was
zu bewegen ich möchte menschen erreichen
münchen überzeugen
und ich finde auch nach wie vor also das
ist ja unverändert so dass wir ein
besseres land haben könnten wenn wir es
anders gestalten
aber wenn man dann irgendwann merkt man
ist in einer funktion wo man unglaublich
viel kraft dafür verwendet dinge zu tun
die eigentlich nichts bewirken also
keine provision die götter rat wirkung
haben sondern wo man wirklich immer nur
müde und müder und müder wird dann wird
man ja auch schlechter mann ist hat ja
auch weniger zeit neue ideen zu
entwickeln
dann muss man irgendwann so ok dafür bin
ich aber nicht in die politik gegangen
ich wollte nicht nur funktionieren ich
wollte was erreichen
hat man vielleicht sind männer robuster
das kann sein wobei ich sagen muss in
jedem punkt habe ich tatsächlich auch
respekt vor frau merkel also robust ich
sehe also was sie jetzt seit den ganzen
jahren an ein termin an einen drucker an
dingen wegsteckt also das können auch
offensichtlich frauen das ist sehr
unterschiedlich aber kann schon sein
dass bei männern oft das mit julien ganz
andere fragen gestellt haben bei uns
frauen ist es direkt zum druck also
dieses diese fragen schon frau würdig
wie schaffen sie das mit haushalt und
kindern und arbeit diese fahrrad mein ex
mann nicht einmal in seinem leben
bekomme nicht ein einziges mal und das
impliziert ja schon dass ich es schaffen
muss diese frage ja ich glaube einer
frau guckt man auch mehr hin wenn sie
müde aussieht und sie frage dann auch
dazu befragt wie sie sehen aber schlecht
aus ich habe also nicht ich habe ja
selber mein mann ist ja auch politiker
und ich glaube es war noch nicht so
häufig dass er gefragt wurde wenn er
müde war ob er müde aussieht also weil
man bei frauen natürlich auch viel
stärker auf diese äußerlichkeiten
also das ist schon eine andere also das
ist eine andere wahrnehmung öffentlich
dass wir noch leben quasi angereichert
wird äußerlich wahrscheinlich ja also es
ist zumindest vielmehr thema also wenn
bei einer frau irgendwas äußerlich nicht
völlig perfekt ist dann wird das ganz
anders thematisiert bei männern gut also
fängt ja bei der kleidung an diesen
sogenannten 1 und nächste woche oder
übernächste woche da wären wir das noch
mal eine halbe stunde bitte
[Musik]